You got this.
>> Eden?
>> Hello.
>> Hi, I'm good welcome
let's head out this way.
So today what's going to
happen is we're going to meet.
>> Hey.
Our IOS candidate is going
to be here pretty soon.
Her portfolio looks really promising.
>> Yeah, I'm just looking at her resume
now and that Mong app that she built.
That's really intuitive.
So, I'm thinking we tackle it like this.
I'll take the behavioral questions.
We'll have Kristen do
the Swift questions, and
then if you could handle
Objective C that would be awesome.
>> Great, yeah, that aught to give
us a good sense of her skills.
It's kind of funny I was looking
at her LinkedIn profile and
I didn't see anything about Objective C.
I guess we'll find out.
Okay, here we are.
Now, do you need anything to drink.
Would you like some tea, some coffee?
>> I'm great, thank you.
>> Okay, let me know if you
have any other questions.
>> Thanks a lot.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You got this.
As long as they don't
ask about Objective C.
No, you wouldn't do that.